في سن الاربعه اعوام يعاني الطفل يعقوب من
سرطان الدم ومع تلقيه جرعات كيماويه في
صنعاء عادت حركته الطبيعيه بعد اشهر من
فقدان الامل في التعافي يعقوب طفل من
النازحين في مارب يعاني الالاف منهم
امراضا مزمنه وحالات سرطان متفاوته
الخطوره في ظل غياب كلي لعياده كشف
ومعالجه السرطان خلال الفتره الماضيه سويت
له فحوصات في كل المختبرات اللي موجوده في
مارب ما توصلت مده اربع شهور كان ولدي هذا
يعتبر مقعد قد هو مقعد فرح الفراش فرحت
صنعاء وديتهم مستشفى الكويت طلع في سرطان
وطلع في الفحصه سرطان سرطان في الدم
هناك فتره يعني بحدود شهر او شهر ونص لما
توصل
[موسيقى]
اصبحت الصنعه زي الخارج
العمله حقها مثلا 100,000 حقنا
مطلع العامل الجاري تم افتتاحه وحده
للسرطان في هيئه مستشفى مارب تقدم خدمات
علاجيه للمرضى ورغم افتقادها للكثير من
الامكانيات تمثل الوحده نواه لمركز كبير
ومتخصص لعلاج الاورام السرطانيه والتخفيف
من معاناه مرضى السرطان في محافظه النفطيه
يتزايد فيها المصابون وتمثل اكبر تجمع
للنزوح في المنطقه
يتم استقبال المريض وفحصه وقبل اعطاء
الجرعه
وتحضيره للعلاج اعطال الجرعه التمهيديه
قبل العلاج الكيماوي ثم بعد ذلك يتم
مراقبته واعطاء العلاج الكيماوي لدينا
احصائيه اوليه من محافظه مارب يحول ما
يقارب 120 مريض سرطان خلال الفتره السابقه
الماضيه
فهناك حاجه ملحه وضروريه في محافظه مارب
لا يوجد وحده او عياده حتى عياده تخصصيه
لعلاج السرطان
127 حاله من مرضى السرطان في مديريات مارب
الثلاث المجاوره لشركات الاستكشافات
والانتاج النفطي رصدتهم منظمه محليه فيما
توفي المئات وربما الالاف من الحالات في
مخيمات النزوح قبل تشخيص الاورام محمود
الحميدي العربيه مارب
متابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات